Next up buddies. You're Molly Webster and Carmen.
All right. Um, okay. Just for a lunch in. But yeah,
so science and
Yay. This is my new thing with my sisters.
I just always go hashtag science cause they get really sick of me trying to
teach the kids sciencey lessons.
It's Hashtag science it. Okay.
So one of the biggest mysteries in biology is how old am I that that doesn't
seem like a mystery.
Well I mean like obviously I'm Molly Webster who's 32 years old who has lived
you know through 32 birthdays I guess. Yeah.
But this is a question of like we know that some cells in our body regenerate
and so it's like how old are those cells? Like how old is my heart right now?
Or like how old my eyeball or how old is my nose? Spleen,
the northwest corner of my kidney. Hmm.
Is this like like a m you know, if I'm three years old now I'm 33 years old.
Are the cells in the 33 year old, are they the same as any of them?
The same as the one when I was three. Is that the question? Yeah,
that's one of the questions. Are any of them the same? If they're not the same,
then how often do they change? Because if you understand that,
then you might be able to like solve injuries,
help people heal faster or fix diseases where cells are,
you know,
messed up like psoriasis or anemia or als or something like that.
But also it just seems so cool to be able to be like,
oh that chunk of my heart is from 1997 yes.
Yet other chunk of my heart is from 1983 yes. Like that.
I would love to know that at the Party of Robert,
I would want to meet the original Robert Cells.
So if there's anybody who's been here since 1947 I'd love to just say hello and
if you just joined me in 2015 well that's nice.
I mean like it would be super cool.
So one of the questions they've had for a long time is,
is there a way that we can try to date cells?
And so they're like, well,
we can't really send anything into the body because that can be toxic.
So the answer for a long time had been no,
and then 2002 ish, this little idea pops up
and it's something called the bomb pop.
Yes.
B o m. B. B o, m B, and then pulse p.
U. L. S. E. Bomb. Pulse. Yeah. To explain,
I threw it too
in the 1940s and fifties we all know this. We
[inaudible]
just it. A lot of atomic bomb.
Any huge
first test was in 1945 trinity tests, New Mexico a few weeks later.
Little note that the first atomic bomb was dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
where you shall continue to use it. So then as World War II comes to an end,
the rest of the world just tries to catch up to the u s bomb or
the Russians. Then after the Russians,
British, French,
the whole cold war basically just continues to unfold. Cool.
All in all over 400 atomic tests.
When off above ground between 19 1945 and 1963 just imagine if only one atom
bomb were to be dropped on an American city,
thousands of persons would be killed instantly. It was a sucky time. Well,
hashtags Zions there one good thing potentially one good thing popped out and
that is an answer to the question of how old are we that somehow came out of the
balm toast. Yeah. How, um, let me explain, do it.
So with every one of those detonations when atomic bomb goes off that would
shoot a whole bunch of stuff up into the atmosphere.
All of these like radioactive elements like CCM and Tony m and all these things.
But also that explosion shoots up a bunch of neutrons and the new tron will
Prasher into nitrogen that's floating in our atmosphere and create c 14,
which is a very special type of carbon.
It has two extra particles in it now is all that bad radioactive stuff starts
falling out of the atmosphere back to the ground.
See 14 doesn't fall out of the sky and it just sort of floats there.
And what happened is over time the wind currents carried c 14 from these test
sites and just spread it all over the planet.
And this Si 14 which is just totally like normal carbon non-harmful.
It just bonds with oxygen and it gets sucked up into plants.
And then animals eat the plants and then we eat the animals or we eat the plants
and then suddenly the see 14 is in us.
So we all have like a little bit of the atomic age in us. Wait,
I wasn't even born in 1963 so w why would it be in me?
That is the cool thing because it hangs out in the air for a long time. So it's,
it's actually still up there. But why does this have anything to do with dating?
Anything? Yes, I'm about to tell you that. Hey, are you there? Hi. Yes I am.
Yeah, her fic,
I'm a senior scientist at Lawrence Livermore national lab,
[inaudible] professor of stem cell research at the Karolinska Institute in
Stockholm.
So in the early two thousands Yoanis is staring down this question of like,
how do I date cells?
And at a certain point he gets together with Bruce because he comes up with this
idea, which is just, Oh, maybe we just look up.
So Derek, there's some groups in Europe.
There's one in particular that's been measuring the atmosphere every two weeks
since the late 1950s it's an incredible data record.
Bruce says,
what the scientists have done is they've taken all of these measurements and
they put them into one chart so you can see the amount of [inaudible] in the
atmosphere over time.
So we, we have this basically a basically a calendar and I could,
I could send you a picture so you can see what, see what the graph looks like.
Yeah, I'd love to see a picture. What you see on that graph is this,
according to Yoanis two 1950
the five it's a pretty flat line with very little variation that's on suddenly
in 1955 with all the bomb tests,
there's a very sharp increase,
a lot of carbon 14 very dramatic increase. That's why they call it a pulse.
And that increase goes all the way up to 1963 when
the Kremlin portraits of communist doctrine is attending Avanade storic event.
When the u s the U K and Soviet Union agreed to stop exploding atomic bombs
above ground,
what's the signing of an atom test ban after that?
There's a gradual decline.
You know, they're just measuring it all the way down so they can just say, oh,
like here's where it was and [inaudible] [inaudible] 80 years where it was in
99020002010 this right here is the coolest part because the amount of
[inaudible] in the atmosphere at any given moment is directly reflected in our
cells, right? So if there's like that much,
see 14 in the atmosphere in September,
1972 then that is going to be mirrored in cells that were born in September,
1972 so it is like this totally perfect birthday calendar.
We can see approximately how long have they been there for 10 years or 20 years
or 30 years. It's like once this idea got out,
every like scientists all over the world are like, Oh yeah,
oh, give me your attention. There's been a new invention.
It didn't take long to see that this might be something cool to do.
It came about because they made a big atomic bomb.
So just to give you a quick sense of some of the work that came out of this.
I spoke to one scientists.
I'm Kirsty Spalding and I work at the Karolinska Institute in Stockholm.
She was working with Eunice and they figured out how to use c 40
in brains. I mean, first of all, the basic question was,
can adult humans make new neurons? She says that for like a hundred years,
the dogma had always been that the neurons we're born with are the ones we die
with.
The problem was she had no way to investigate this and she couldn't use it in
humans,
even if they were dead humans until she figured out a technique where she could
like extract brain cells and see how much the 14 was in there. Yeah, exactly.
And it turns out the next best thing to human, here's a horse,
because horses can live for quite some years, decades.
So every second Tuesday I would go out to the local Alberta,
the local slaughter house, an hour away,
and I mean I was a vegetarian surrounded by caucuses and they would bring the
horses head out to me and I had to figure out how to get the brain out of its
head and what you actually had to like cut,
open the skull and get to the brain yourself. I mean, the second time I went,
I took my boyfriend with me because I was like, I can't do this. Physically,
they actually had a circular saw and I actually discovered that the, the skull,
the bone across the top, the nose of the horses is quite thin.
So that was a much easier access point. This is really gross discussion.
Did you ever see your research going that way? No, absolutely not. Not at all.
But what she saw when she finally moved her research from Horseheads to humans
was turnover. We found quite robust levels of new neurons in adulthood.
Once the onuses team showed that this worked,
scientists got excited and people started to date things and not just cells.
So can I tell you the ages? Okay.
The baseline ages we knew before c 14 was that skin was like 14 days old.
1440. Oh that's only for 28 days. Yeah. So like two weeks. Um,
the surface level of your gut.
The like the skin on your gut I guess was five days. Five days.
That's even shorter than skin does.
That's like the surface of the intestine or the surface of the, yeah,
the lining. That's like, cause that's everything.
Scraping all that food going down. So though that doesn't surprise me.
And then with see 14, the,
the deeper muscly part of the intestine,
the average is 15.1 years. 15.1 years.
Oh, big difference. Weight, 15.9, 15.9 years old.
Fat Cells was another one that they did. Uh, 10 years old. 10 years old.
Yeah. Interesting. Why would a festival need to last that long?
10 Years Towards your youth?
Do they have any idea? They don't know. Huh? Do they know that? Like,
what would be one of the oldest part of us, your um, your cortex,
which is, uh,
like the part of your brand that does like abstract thinking or your voluntary
movements that's as old as you are. Really? Huh.
So if you want to know one of the oldest parts of you,
the oldest cell is probably in your part of your brain and it'll be like your
cortical neuron will that fits.
If I think of myself as the stories I tell myself,
like when you get Alzheimer's and you lose your stories and you lose your mind,
people say,
but the interesting thing though is the hippocampus is where you keep all your
memories.
And they saw that your hippocampus does make a bunch of new neurons.
Yes. So in the hippocampus, that's Yunus Friesen. Again,
the oats gets approximately 1400 new hippocampal neurons per day.
Really? Yeah. And then each of those neurons will live like 20, maybe 30 years.
So does that mean that the part of Robert's brain where he keeps the stories,
he tells himself that part is being made new every 20 or 30 years? Yeah.
It's a strange thing that like your oldest stories could be stored in baby
little neurons. It is weird. Yeah. I remembered going to
Kyoto and it's like the oldest most beautiful temple in Kyoto.
It has exactly the form that it had, you know,
hundreds of years ago.
But when you walk in the the walls and the floors and the roofing and they've
been restored, they've been restored actually over and over again.
Cause in Japan what they call old is the form.
It's the shape of the building you go to happens though and you go up to the
Acropolis and you stand in the Parthenon there you're standing in the very
temple that Perricone stood in. It's the same place. Exactly.
Same materials. So I can,
in Greece they believe that the original stuff is the,
is what you preserve. And in Japan they don't, they think it's just the form.
And I was thinking of this thing you're doing is sort of a little bit like that.
Like I was thinking, I'm much more Greek than I am Japanese
cause I wanna know like what my original cells are if they where they are in me.
Yeah. But my question is, Maxine meant more basic.
It's like why does part of me get to re reborn in the other parts of me don't
like why not all of me get to be reborn? Because if all of you is being reborn,
you would just crumble into dust. No. Why not?
Why is only certain parts get to regenerate?
It's interesting because they don't know. They said the next,
they said basically this question of how old is a cell?
They said no one was asking. Everyone wondered this,
but no one was asking this question because they never had the tools to ask it.
So now they're just starting to ask those questions. It's,
but there's a problem.
Okay.
This balm pulse that we've been depended on in the last decade to start
answering all these questions is going away. Really every day a little more.
That c 14 gets sucked out of the air. So how much time do we have left?
15 years. It's gone by 2030 give or take. Yeah.
So we need to get questions answered now because we really are working against
the clock for many things we want to look at.
I talked to this Alzheimer's researcher who was trying to figure out like the
chronology of the disease,
like when certain like pathologies form in the brain and he was kind of just
like, I just wish I had a little more time
[inaudible]
and when I think about this,
like I was thinking about this on the subway this morning,
like I was looking around and I was thinking, you know, I'm on the l train,
it's a bunch of like 30 year old kids or something and I was like these and
they're all reading or something,
drinking their expensive lattes and like these people are so far away from
thinking about the Cold War or atomic bombs or anything like that.
And they're all walking around with like the secret signal from the atomic
period inside of them.
And then that little signal is like binging out like knowledge about their
shoulder and their elbow and their liver and the west side of the liver and the
east side of the liver and like different parts of their heart and the fact that
it's now going away and how like someone born in
2040 too is just going to be really boring and like we know they're not going to
have any insights into who they are yet.
Sort of makes me inclined to very peacefully want to
exploding another atomic bomb. What? No, no,
no one know why you forget all the poisons that that is not a benign event.
That's sort of an experimental pick her up or that is extra extra stuff till the
air fill my dream. I have to kill your jingle. Dumb, dumb dream.
The how long have you been with the red new bar?
[inaudible] what did he do for good?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] like that. [inaudible]
do you want
[inaudible] telephone phone? Well then no man, no, there's power.
Oh my God.
Alone low than that kind of journalistic
with one sweep of power known by God.
No.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
producer Molly Webster and special thanks to Henry crude, Mark Lovell.
Happy Valentine's date, magnesium.
I'd go blind watching you burn magnesium.
Iodine is cute the way it sublimated and yes,
I'll put lithium in water to watch it scoot about,
but my heart belongs to you. Magnesium,
the hot white flame,
the abandoned the slowness of you becoming your own fuse.
Mercury is beautiful. Yes, but it's you.
Magnesium
[inaudible]
the way you burn from me, the way you leave.
Nothing of yourself behind.
We are flying over Greenland. Yeah, elbow is too close.
Mine on the airplane,
armrest down there.
They are excavating uranium from beneath the Arctic ice and selling
indiscriminately.
Though from here I can only see the white of ice sheets in glacier topped
mountains.
This is an island of fishing rigs and colorful houses,
cod and cat fish, stew and tomato cream.
Once I thought every isotope in me is radio active.
I make the people who love me sick.
This is a teenage way of thinking.
Yeah.
Wait,
you have uncovered a glowing spark in the pristine frozen places within me.
[inaudible]
that was uranium from poet Emily Hockaday read by Joanie's, Abbott Pratt,
and before that, happy Valentine's Day, magnesium by Jason Schneiderman,
performed by Sam Breslin writes, Judy has a middle name in this thing. So Dylan,
right? Yeah. Come on up. We're going to get into an elevator,
push the button and go down. And I mean all the way down.
I'm Robert Krulwich. Chad dickless a boom rod. We'll continue in a moment.
[inaudible].